URS HOLZLE: Last year, we
committed to continuously drive
down costs for our customers
in alignment with Moore's law.
And since then, we announced
three major price reductions.
And we continue to
lead the industry
in combining strong performance
with low cost as well
as flexible, commitment-free
pricing options.
We believe Google Cloud Platform
delivers better performance
at lower cost than
other cloud providers.
You may wonder how
we're able to do this.
First, we're creating
infrastructure
that's tailored to your
workload, not the other way
around.
Earlier this year, we
introduced nearline storage
to dramatically reduce
storage costs by up to 70%
for many classes of
content and data.
And more recently, we
announced preemptible VMs,
a new class of machine
tailored specifically
for stateless applications,
such as Hadoop processing
and short-duration
batch workloads.
Preemptible VMs can lower
your costs by as much as 70%
compared to standard VMs.
And they're perfect for adding
firepower to data processing
applications.
Secondly, we provide you with
the most appropriate billing
plan so you can save
on costs automatically.
You shouldn't have to
spend hours or days
calculating rate plans in
different classes of machines.
We believe that the cloud
should do that for you.
And for that reason,
we pioneered a number
of innovations in pricing,
including per-minute billing
and sustained use discounts.
Options such as these
significantly lower your cost
and are provided to
you automatically.
Third, we don't force
you to prepay to get
the discounts you deserve.
Signing long-term contracts
reduces your flexibility
in a rapidly
changing environment.
As your business grows, the
types of compute resources
you need change as well.
For example, you may start
off on a standard VM.
But as you grow, a
new class of machine
may result in dramatic savings.
Reserved instance pricing
or other prepay schemes
lock you not only
into the price,
but also into a machine
class and a location.
This works only
if you don't grow
or if you have a very
good crystal ball.
So we give you the flexibility
to change regions or classes
of machines to meet
your changing business
needs with no penalty.
And finally, we're establishing
firm price performance
benchmarks based on Moore's Law.
So as infrastructure
becomes more efficient
and the price of the underlying
hardware continues to decline,
we are committed to pass
those savings on to you.
So taken together,
we want to make sure
that our cloud platform
provides the lowest
total cost of ownership and
the highest performance.
[MUSIC PLAYING]